I think there's ever a reason to believe
that Seattle will be the capital of
social entrepreneurship within the next
ten years meaning that though the city
will be the prime influencer and a
geographical sense of what it means to
take an entrepreneurial back to solving
social and environmental issues my name
is Michael Looney Libous I'm a serial
entrepreneur in Seattle I've been doing
startups for 20 years my name is Brian
how I am the founder of hub Seattle and
that's the space that we're currently in
hubs a membership community for social
entrepreneurs so entrepreneurs started
taking market driven approaches to
social and environmental issues the
event was something we called social
aunt weekend and the Sochi errant stands
for social entrepreneur or social
enterprise depending on what mood were
in we had hosted a startup weekend a few
weeks previously and got some advice
from their team and they do incredible
work Startup Weekend has multiple events
every single weekend of the year all the
way across the world with a very similar
format but without the focus on social
or good coming out of it so it came out
of a desire to really create a more
healthy environment here in Seattle for
entrepreneurs who wanted to focus on
social financial and environmental
returns we had some incredible mentor
show up the mayor of Seattle kicked us
off on Friday night with a good speech
about about change really he came in the
exceedingly slow change in his world
yeah hoping we could show them something
faster and we lost 13 companies 50 hours
later so I say we probably did a pretty
good job of that one that I really like
that of the weekend was share box but
for profit tool lending library so you
know normal libraries you pay for your
taxes but private libraries people pay a
fee this is be a fee but not for books
but for tools and their their
implementation was to do it inside a
shipping container so take a old
shipping container refurbish it to be a
library and stick it in a parking lot or
an unused space in a neighborhood so
that people have access to tools right
not just rental but but you join it and
you
you give them your extra tools and in
exchange you get access to other
people's tools another company that had
a interesting pret agree was see how
farm brokers sophiana farm brokers began
with Mayor Mike McGinn and his opening
speech and about two-thirds of the way
in his speech he started talking about
problems that the city was facing and
some potential solutions then he paused
and said I guess I'm pitching which was
encouraging because he came into the
night saying what is a social
entrepreneur I'm not familiar with this
term and 15 minutes later he was
pitching an idea for social enterprise
the city has extra land that's unused
and a separate problem he was having was
there some some refugees in this in the
city who only know how to farm and say
said well why don't we take those two
problems and put them together and solve
both problems at the same time by taking
the unused land interning at the urban
farms change within City Hall is slow
right for the city to go put together a
program to go do something like this
they could potentially do it might take
them a decade all right versus a
start-up who had an idea to go do this
do it as an online service or some other
version of a service could probably get
it done much quicker so we hit it done
by Sunday yeah it is possible that the
city seattle in two or three or four
years could solve that problem it's in
fact solved on Bainbridge Island so I
live on Bainbridge Island we have a
non-profit it's called Friends of the
farm they manage the city-owned property
that is farmland but if Seattle solved
it it wouldn't be solved for Portland or
San Francisco or New York City or any
other place in the world but if a if a
for-profit or nonprofit if a social
enterprise solved it they would then
have a platform that they could go and
sell our partner or whatever the
business model is with every city in the
world Richard Branson probably said it
best actually he said the reason why we
need social entrepreneurs is because
they think about leverage scale and
impact something that NGO and the
government world's have not done in as
efficient away or as inspiring the way
business women and businessmen to think
about how do I take the small thing
great good leverage how is this going to
scale you
I'm a for-profit guy yeah I've worried
about problems that can be solved with
for-profit companies but even when I
work with companies that are nonprofit
companies these days they have to be
sustainable companies must be trippin
just because they're non profit doesn't
mean they're not viable and sustainable
in terms of money in from from customers
or stakeholders all right so you know it
matters whether you want to be totally
miss and driven or totally profit driven
either way you got to make more money
than ya then you spend